[Music]
there is compassionate inquisitiveness
and his care for others this professor
truly embodies what makes the GSB
special it is for all these reasons that
I now ask you to join us in
congratulating the 2018 recipient of the
distinguished Teaching Award
professor al Mitsuru
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you everyone on the committee for
those kind words and award it's
obviously a great honor to join the
illustrious colleagues who have won this
award before me I want to especially
thank the talk to the Hat group my MBA
twos from last year you know who you are
we want largest in numbers but you all
sure did make a loud noise and thank you
for making the noise and making me feel
this appreciated those were very
generous and kind words but I want to
start by thanking my wife who's there
and and kids actually because you know
innovation in teaching it starts at home
actually because most of the times I've
realized when I've tried to teach them
anything it doesn't work but in the
words of famous Rocky Balboa it's not
about how hard you hit it's about how
you can get hit and then still keep
moving forward and that's what I try to
do though I'm still looking for
succeeded success at home with this
award I'm hoping that I can point to
some more credibility that I have now
hopefully that'll work I have to say
that you all attribute it too much
credit to me I would be amiss if I
didn't thank my finance colleagues
especially those who helped shape the
change in the curriculum and allowed us
to think about these things so it
professor Josh Rauh annalistic and Peter
de marzo in in in particular thank you
and other colleagues like Tim McQuaid
who have gone ahead and implemented
these changes but to be honest you know
all of these changes cannot happen
without all of you here all of you have
been very gracious in your thoughts in
your inputs in your feedback been very
patient in both absorbing and
acknowledging things that have worked
and things that haven't worked but this
is the tolerance for failure which leads
to a lot of innovation not only in the
classroom but in the real world and so I
hope that you will continue to be
patient because that's going to lead to
more innovation which is something that
we always want now I should note that if
there is any innovation that's working
it's obviously the work of my colleagues
and me and if it's not working it's
because of the feedback from all of you
but more seriously in the finance
classes I have taught I have emphasized
thinking about economic trade-offs
incentives
and I have suggested that the simplest
way to think about this is the Mickey
Mouse balance sheet which those who have
taken my class know what I'm talking
about and thinking about the mm
framework now you know knowing where the
free cash flows come from and where they
go but you know these are interesting
frameworks but if you think about the
big picture which I like to sort of talk
about in all of my classes we are at
very interesting times at Crossroads
really and that requires us to take all
of these frameworks that you're learning
in finance or other classes and push
them really in directions that we
haven't sort of really tested so
business government policy society they
are all interacting in ways and making
changes at a pace that we haven't seen
before
there is disruption innovation but they
are disrupted and a large number of them
there is growth but there is also
polarization and in this government
which is trying to balance all of these
different constituents sometimes
successfully sometimes not so much
and in this ecosystem in this
environment the question for you all
like the committee posed they stole my
thunder is how are you going to define
success what's success for you it could
be about in a wearing it could be about
generating free cash flows making money
a lot of jobs growth but I'm hoping that
you'll be more fearless coming out of
GSB and are going to push this a little
bit further and when you do that free
cash flows are not going to be free
anymore it will require you to challenge
yourselves and redefine what you mean by
success pretty regularly really and when
you do I'm hoping that when you go out
from GSB you will come back and you know
give us inputs and feedback like you
have while you were here so that you
challenge us because that's the only way
we build a knowledge stock on which the
next generations can really build on and
you know I like to call it standing on
the shoulder of giants which is all of
you and us where next generations can
stand and look far but I was at a
Midwest GST where I was told no no no
that is old school the new
you're standing on the shoulder of
dinosaurs because then you can see even
further so whatever you guys need to go
out and then come back and and let us
know what are we doing right and what
are we not doing wrong but the bottom
line is that the problems are complex
and the solutions are unknown but my
hope is that all of you who have taken
my classes and we have learned together
are gonna use some of this and as you
are going to be figuring out the answers
which will help us to together change
lives change organizations and change
the world to make it a better place than
what you and I got when we sort of
started so with that again thank you
everyone really appreciate it and this
is going to be a very memorable day for
many years to come for me thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]